ALAN SHANSKE: Hi, my name
is Alan Shanske.
I'm an intern on the Android
Team at Google.
And today I'll be talking
about Listview dragging
animations.
So the demo today is going to
be a simple Listview, where
you can long-click on an item,
then drag it around.
And you'll see that as you drag
the item around it will
actually replace and move
around, swap the underlying
data set, with the other
Listview items.
So the main trick to doing this
animation was to realize
that we're not actually moving
the views of the list you
round but what you're going
to do is create a Bitmap
drawable, overlay the Bitmap
drawable on top of the
Listview, and then as you're
dragging your finger around,
what's actually going to happen
is that we'll be moving
the Bitmap drawable, but not
the view which is actually
contained inside the Listview.
So let's jump straight
to a demo.
And so here we have just
a list of cheeses.
We can click and hold on one of
the items in order to get
hold of it, and then as we drag
it around you'll see that
the items around it animate into
place while swapping the
underlying data set change
and moving around.
Furthermore, if the Bitmap
drawable, if the hover view
that we have goes outside the
bounds of the Listview, you
can see that the Listview starts
scrolling and also at
the same time swapping elements
as we need to.
Same thing goes when
it's above the
valance of the Listview.
When you let go of it, the item
just animates back into
place into the Listview,
and normal Listview
interactions ensue.
So let's just jump
straight to code.
The main file to look at here
is Dynamic Listview which
extends a Listview object.
And as you scroll down, the
first important thing to see
is that we added an OnLongClick
item listener.
So what happens when an item
has been selected via
LongClick event we have
to do a few things.
One, we have to determine what
the position is of the
ClickDown event, we have to
determine which item was
selected, and then we
also [INAUDIBLE]
the view that was selected from
that spot, as well as the
item that we associate
with it.
Then the important thing that's
happening is we call
this method called,
GetAndAddHoverView, which
returns a Bitmap drawable.
And what that does is capture
the contents of the view that
was selected, it takes a screen
shot of it, adds the
little black border around that
we saw, right here in
GetBitmapWithBorder, and the
screen shot is captured right
here in GetBitmapFromView.
So once we capture the Bitmap
and we insert it into the
Bitmap drawable, the important
thing to note is that Bitmap
drawables have the
notion of bounds.
So by modifying the bounds we
can modify where it's located,
and then when we draw it on top
of the Listview it'll move
around accordingly to how
the bounds are updated.
OK, so moving on to the
OnLongItemClick listener, the
important thing to note is that
when an item has been
selected via LongItemClick event
there's a few things
that we need to do.
One, you need to determine what
the position is of the
Down event was, you need to
determine the item number that
was selected, and you also need
to retrieve the view that
was clicked as well.
So then what we're going to do
is call this method called,
GetAndAddHoverView which all
it's going to do is return a
Bitmap drawable that has the
same contents as the view that
was selected.
Using a couple methods here
year below, we're going to
capture the contents of the
screen, add a black border
around it which you saw in the
demo, and then we'll throw all
of that into the Bitmap drawable
which then will be
overlaid over our Listview.
The important thing to note is
that Bitmap drawables do have
the notion of bounds, so if we
do update the bounds of the
Bitmap drawable we'll be able to
move it around accordingly
on the screen to where we want
it to be in response to the
user touches.
That can get an AddHoverView,
the important thing to note is
that we have to make sure the
visibility of the view that
was selected is set
to invisible.
So it's still going to be in the
Listview, and the Bitmap
drawable is going to be
overlaying the Listview, but
these two objects are completely
independent even
though they correspond in
response to the user touches.
The other trick that was
implemented in order to do
this item swapping animation
is to know that whenever
you're going to swap an item
you're only ever going to swap
it with the item right above
it, or right below it.
So that's why whenever a swap
animation takes place, or a
dragging event begins, you
always need to retrieve the
above item ID, and the
below item ID.
By returning True for a stable
item IDs in this table array
adapter, which is a custom array
adaptor implemented in
this project, what you're
essentially saying is that
every single item in your
Listview has a unique ID that
you maintain yourself, and that
will never change for
that corresponding object.
So we know that this above and
below item ID will never
change for the above and below
views around which are
currently animating.
There's some logic here
in GetViewForID and
GetPositionForID where I was
able to actually retrieve a
view given some item
ID, and vice versa.
You can look at this later
in more detail if you're
interested in seeing
how I did that.
But the important thing here is
that in this batch draw, if
I do have that Bitmap
drawable it will be
drawn onto the screen.
So what I'm doing here, if I'm
not in dragging event then my
hover cell is going
to be null, I
won't be drawing anything.
If my hover cell is a non-null
object then I will draw it,
it'll overlay the Listview
since I'm first calling
[INAUDIBLE]
and only then drawing the
hover cell on top of it.
So now in OnTouch event there's
a few things that need
to be done.
When an ActionDown occurs I
don't yet know whether or not
that's going to become a
dragging event or not, so
either way I need to retrieve
the x and y-coordinates of the
touch event.
Then in ActionMove this is
where I actually move the
hover cell in response
to the user touches.
Firstly, I calculate the Delta
by how much the user has
already moved his or her finger,
and then if I am
indeed in a dragging event
then I need to offset the
bounds of my hover cell.
So here I offset the bounds, I
update the bounds, and then I
call Invalidate which will call
DispatchDraw, draw the
Listview, and then draw the
hover cell on top of it.
The other thing I need to do is
call HandleCellSwitch which
is where the logic for
determining whether an item
cell swap is going
to take place.
The way this works is I have a
couple bullions that determine
whether or not my moving cell,
my Bitmap drawable has been
shifted up or downwards enough
to actually completely overlap
the cell that's above
or below it.
If that is the case, then I
determine whether or not it
was indeed moved up or moved
down and retrieve the item ID
corresponding to the cell
which will be swapped.
After I do that, I need to
swap the elements in the
underlying data set change and
notify the adapter that data
has indeed been changed.
So what's going to happen when
the NotifyDataSetChange method
is called is that the Listview
knows that the data is
different so it's going to
invoke a layout and everything
in the Listview will
be re-drawn.
Before I do that, I want to make
sure that the cells that
I need to be visible remain
visible, while the cell that
is still in the swapping and
the dragging event is still
invisible, so I update
those here.
And then I also update my above
and below view, because
now that a soft-swap has indeed
occurred in the data
set, either the cell above it or
below it is now different.
OK.
And now the most important thing
here to actually have
the cell animated to place when
a data set change has
occurred is OnPreDrawListener.
So what OnPreDrawListener does
is give you a call back where
after OnMeasure and OnLayout
event are called, so after all
the values for all of your
views, all of your widget on
screen have already been
updated, but OnDraw has not
yet been called.
What this lets you do is
essentially gives you the
power to access all the final
values that all the widgets
will have, but before they've
actually been drawn onto the.
Screen
So you can do some custom
drawing here, given the final
the values, and then once this
completes, you can return True
for all of the other
default drawing to
actually take place.
So now in OnPreDraw, you
always want to remove
PreDrawListener if you only
want to get in here once.
And then what you want to do is
grab the cell that's being
swapped, not the cell you're
dragging, but the cell that's
going to swap into
the new place.
You offset it by delta y because
you know that it's
currently in its final position,
but you want to be
in it's old position prior
to the date set change.
So we calculate the delta
y, we set that to be the
translation, and then we simply
use an Object Animator
to animate the transition
y back to
zero with some duration.
So as you saw in the demo this
will actually achieve that
sliding effect when the data
set change has occurred.
Strolling down furthermore we
have SwapElements which is a
simple method swapping the
underlying data set.
And then TouchesEventsEnded,
the only important thing to
note here is this Object
Animator that we create, and
all this does is animate the
Bitmap drawable back into its
correct position in the Listview
when a user has
lifted his finger up from the
phone, as well as reset all
our variables back to their
default values.
The other important thing that
was really tricky to do is
determining how we can actually
have the Listview
scroll while you're dragging a
cell and making sure that all
the above and below item
IDs get updated as
we need them to.
So here in HandleMobileScroll
is a method that
gets called when we--
so HandleMobileCellScroll is a
method that gets called every
single time the user moves his
finger, and that calls this
method here.
All this does is use a few
methods available in view to
determine whether or not the
bounds of the hover cell are
either below or above the
bounds of the Listview.
If that is the case, then we'll
call SmoothScrollBy
either up or downwards,
and return True.
And by returning True what we're
saying is that we are in
a scrolling state, in a manual
scrolling state created by the
fact that the bounds
are outside the
bounds of the Listview.
And if that is True, then we'll
know that after a scroll
has completed we should continue
scrolling because
we're still in the manual
scrolling state invoked by the
bounds of the hover cell.
So in order to do that, we add
the ScrollListener right here.
And what that does is every
single time an OnScroll event
has changed, has taken place, it
checks whether the first or
a last visible cell in the
ListView has been updated.
If that's the case, then that
means that new first or last
item is a potential candidate
for an above or below cell to
be swapped, and that means we
need to change those above and
below item IDs.
So we call those methods here,
and after a scroll is
completed we call
HandleMobileScroll once again
to keep that scrolling event
continuing and keep calling
SmoothScrollBy as long as the
bounds are outside the bounds
of the Listview.
So pretty much, you can look at
the code if you want to see
any more detail.
But you can take Dynamic
Listview extend it, include in
your project, and that's how
you can achieve a Listview
which can then be dynamically
rearranged using user
[INAUDIBLE].
Thanks.